okay echa echa boys Aiko babble here
with our main man Kanye West I am we
just started the quest [ __ ] quested
welcome to the bad thing ok let's do
this am I why am I they rarely wear
clothes I can't have my bet I ok metal
box not thank you thank you and thank
you episod actually digesting ok ok
let's say here let's say here I have it
I foot locker than that thanks that's
they're not Dex the [ __ ] is a slice
why is my anus or
yeah that's like that's i got very much
toaster ok what's in here rich and out
of takeout you never know when I need it
God God God God God God God God gun
what the [ __ ] is going on there this I
can't for what size
hello there
talk to the toaster that's it
that's eggs eggs I never passed that a
snack shave his aunt a pre-warp [ __ ]
[ __ ] be [ __ ] and [ __ ] paste
snitches okay not a drink oh ok ok ok
yes very much I'll take that now I'll
take that Oh at this yes I'll take that
[ __ ] out here yes like that like the
sound all right there ok let's say yeah
say yeah God God mm I Shane yes I'll
tell dad thank you ok can't draw my
weapon what is as like a calf like just
kidding like I like a camps I've heard
three years there they tried to convert
me but they're not working I ate too
much in the medicine was ineffective I
saw i heard that pacification fields
kick you all right nobody I'll handle
this be warned intruder you are in the
presence of a my teeth right Oppenheimer
which one of you self-professed geniuses
has been adjusting my volume knob was it
what did you wait huh Oh doctor Oh was
it likely story Oh couldn't spot you
neurons we're in a lattice biomed kill
hey what me breaking news climb it
wasn't me all right I'm the robotically
engineer hey just sound waves that's it
you always do this you always me enough
eyes are you using great well I forgot
what I was saying did did it just say
something and I guess it's all about a
night Oh as if this situation couldn't
get any what dr. climb if my hypothesis
is correct if so it's just your head I
know what it is taller I want and are
those penises I see wriggling on its
feet I believe those are toes dr. Klein
little I don't recall the human penis
ever being that large it depends on
don't frame of reference dr. oh look at
its little nose with its two orifices
for ingesting noses hell of attack dr.
Klein well yes Ben I agree with Boris is
history gone sir hey have you been in
the men's hats again if we slow down our
oral processor all of you lump those
were words weren't they in the form of
all perhaps as we were ruthlessly
lobotomizing it with wait if what your
thira then dr. clock if it isn't my old
colleagues the mighty think tank of a
mountain peak fools oh it is i talked to
Mobius trap even though my deadly Robo
scorpions for even the technology sealed
it up it best yeah Mobius always the
sick what are you going to do there's no
way we can breach the Forbidden Zone law
forbidden except dr. Mobius and technol
and dr. movie was asked for a bottom up
if this lobata might responded now
decline please but what of its brain we
scoop that out wait yes it's so we're if
we ask it politely and leave the part
about the unmet
we removed your brain yes rain
extraction once the brain was out then
came back up yay no need to brag
wherever your Brooke notes up this is
fortunate in many respects if you were
brain circumventing the pass of a cake
reminds me of although and once it had
removed the brain and I misplaced it
rather than let them send their signals
I removed first oh wait I mean second
spine look at me to be correct you
should say the isle de it worked so hard
on your surgeon that although dark junk
heap was one after that the drain if so
why does it look like it's a most
probable a problem we yes maybe just
maybe excellent this is turning out much
better I'll greet oh and I'll use my
settle down eight hey
page is correct semantics this does not
mean